une petite ruelle juste à l'ouest du
boulevard pie-ix normalement daniel la
treille observe les nombreuses oiseaux
dans sa cour mais ce qu'elle nous montre
ce sont des trous à rats car les voici
les spécimens qui peuplent son quotidien
depuis cet été une colonie de rats et
leur progéniture ils sortent qui il rend
passé j'en ai vu ici le j'en ai vu un
énorme vraiment et elle n'est pas la
seule
ça fait cinq ans que j'habite sinon
j'avais jamais jamais eu ce problème là
on veut poquet des rucks installe
partout dans les rues afin qu'ils jouent
ici
[Musique]
les travaux du service rapide par bus à
quelques dizaines de mètres sont montrés
du doigt est-ce que la nuisance vient de
là aucun doute dans l'esprit de cette
exterminateurs du quartier a theory
daver paroisse d'avoir signer les égouts
sont étanches
ils vont rester à l'intérieur des égouts
daniel latreille a donc demandé des
comptes à la ville sans résultat mais
madame à montréal il ya des pas dans
votre cour messier alors elle s'est
tournée vers la stm j'ai signé par 49
personnes
j'ai jamais eu aucun retour de rien
c'est ridicule à ceux des transports de
montréal la ville de montréal ça la vie
de montréal
est ce qu'on peut se parler est-ce qu'on
peut s'assurer que les normes soient
respectées
il y a deux ans l'administration avait
rejeté une motion de l'opposition qui
visait à limiter la propagation des rats
aux abords des chantiers et il y aurait
des solutions simples à faire mathieu
chartier
avant de quitter qui met une plaque
un morceau de la route quelque chose
pour fermer des goûts qui est
responsable car ce qui s'est produit ici
pourrait se répéter
ils vont ouvrir les égouts font rire les
rues à d'autres endroits on veut pas que
ça se reproduise notre hiver la stm nous
a répondu avoir demandé à l'entrepreneur
de veiller à la propreté et à
l'entretien des toilettes du chantier
quant à la ville elle assure effectuer
les inspections lorsque demander ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal